how come girls when they take steroids
their clits get all huge that's a
viralization effect it's the masculine
features that occur so is it turning
into a penis no it's not turning to a
penis oh
[Music]
everybody welcome back
to another spicy episode of the hot seat
today featuring Mr Jared feathers
everybody
[Applause]
could we get a fun double bicep
God damn holy [__] it's like the widest
person you've ever had on this [__]
Channel yeah for sure this chair is
gonna break it really feels like it's
going to God damn what the [__] his goal
is to be a robbing boner finally broke
no it's not going to break the real
swords this Vin right here yeah is like
the size of my whole boner
that's way bigger than mine that's a big
vein when did you start getting into
fitness oh god oh I was well you're
about to get into some real deep [__]
right oh wait wait we gotta do Bart's
Cold quest wait this is a hot seat
that's just like a bio question that's a
good start we just talked about the
whole like let's make this segment
different than a regular if I can get to
know you I don't know if Joe is
listening the whole time no but I think
it's a good beginning if this is the
first video that someone clicks yeah
let's do it okay we introduce him as a
bodybuilder this can get hot back to the
tradition of the hot seat we're supposed
to start with a cold yeah let's do it
with Bart then we'll Circle back to all
right unless that's the coldest one
we're gonna happen
all right Bart feel free okay oh boy if
you had to recolor a bumblebee
what other colors would you choose the
brightest ones possible so I'm not
getting [__] stung like neon green
yeah well that'll probably blending with
the sky a little too much like red as
[__] right like red and white because
there's two colors red because it's
black and yellows what doesn't go with
red at all green like crisp perfect
Christmas but green is like they're in
nature there's green things in nature oh
you don't want it to be halfway blending
you want to be like red and maybe purple
or something bright and pink oh yeah
that blends too much red and pink as
long as if I saw a giant ass red thing
though you know what I'm saying yeah so
you make a cotton candy all right when
did you first start at bodybuilding I
promise you it's gonna get hot sure all
right what is it gonna Fitness First
into fitness yeah so I kind of played
Sports as a kid and then my first time
in the gym I was 16 maybe 17 my junior
year High School
I basically went to the gym because my
mom had just had surgery on a tumor that
was growing near her brain she has a
false tympanic membrane yeah part of
your ear
um and I just didn't want to see her die
basically so she was at home basically
it looked like she was gonna die and we
were all just kind of like wow so you're
just trying to like escape the situation
Oh I thought you were trying to Get
Swole to save her pick her up you're not
gonna die mom just to shake her hard I
was gonna stay alive she's already
having seizures
[Laughter]
yeah no so I just like we all thought
she was gonna die for quite some time
and I was like I don't want to be around
so Jim was your escape space yeah which
I would literally this is not a joke I
would train for 11 hours a day what the
dumbest [__] 11 hours so you would you
bench press that whole time yeah yeah
like everything like full body I would
basically go to the gym in the morning
before school for like an hour and a
half
then during lunch I would go as well
instead of eating
um and then I would come back and eat
all my friends like leftovers Foods
because we didn't have food at home we
were poorest this high school and then I
would train in my weight class and then
I somehow managed to become a TA for a
wage class too which was back to back oh
[__] and we had that block scheduling so
like red and black days those are our
school colors so they were what does
that make the classes like two hours
instead of the traditional 30 minutes or
something so both those times I would
train and then after football practice
or if we weren't in football season I
would just go to the gym for three more
hours after school the school gym yeah
oh holy and so that's when you got into
like you just a dick just basically fell
in love with it and I like fell out of
love with sports like I got recruited to
the schools for football and [__] and I
I loved it but I fell out of love with
like the sports and way more with like
oh training is fun and helping other
people train is fun okay let's start up
a little bit when was the first time you
ever took steroids what made you do it
and what's going through your mind I
like that that's how we that's how we
keep it hot skip 10 years before he
jerked off into a tin can or was it uh
yeah if there's a drug off into cancer
I'm gonna ask that question later yeah
yeah what was going through your mind at
the time were you like
scared absolutely yeah I passed out um I
learned about anabolic steroids for two
years prior to actually taking them
um
I actually learned from one of my
colleagues who does the NDA stuff uh one
hour consultation every single week for
a year and a half so you did it like
with a person that was very very
knowledgeable oh okay actually like it
wasn't a guy in the gym like you want to
get buffered bro he's like check this
out uh so like yeah yeah if you guys are
actually interested in this [__] like
team evil GSP uh Broderick Chavez he's
one of the smartest guys in the world
about this stuff and then uh Joe Jeffrey
also um physique Collective but I
basically the guy I consulted with
Broderick uh
when it was finally time to like do it
do it it was after my last natural
bodybuilding competitive season I was
like okay I'm gonna go in a natural Pro
Show maybe I'll do the natural world
championships and try to become the
Natural World Champ I didn't get that
far I was like [__] it it's time I had
been 10 years natural so I was on a
Skype call with him uh my mentor
and my girlfriend at the time who was a
nurse which thankfully she was a nurse
um I was laying on the bed and we were
Skyping those two and they were
explaining like what we should do how to
go about the process and she she does it
she's a nurse so it was fine she pushed
it but I felt it and I passed out
immediately I have the video and
everything is it because it's the first
time you ever got a needle in you or am
I not in me but like the that [__] hurt
it's oil-based oh yeah it flared up for
like a week and it continued to oil base
did you you get a shot in your ass
that's where I did it first why the butt
and not here well my ass is gigantic
yeah it is yeah it is so wouldn't it
take longer longer for what for it to
hit
because it's the because you got a big
old butt
I get your thinking but no it's
intramuscular so it just it gets into
the system when it gets into the system
so look at any muscle so if you shoot at
subcutaneous which is into the skin like
that releases into your bloodstream
slower but once you're in the muscle
you're in the muscle in it yeah why
don't you hit another muscle why does
that have to be the butt muscle yeah why
don't you hit why don't you hit the vein
like when we go to the you don't want to
do that you don't put in the van it'll
go straight to the lungs
sure see I don't know no medicine yeah
yeah good thing you do those
consultations intravenous is for other
stuff um
but
I did the glutes first because I was
thinking okay big muscle like if there
is some flaring up it'll be a little
more distributed when you say flare it
up is like inflamed or yeah like it's
super red oh wow it's called pip post
injection uh paint
um I had a [__] load of it I still get
it even now like is it just one butt
cheek gets really inflated like you got
a bee sting you can't it can't yeah if
you especially if you do it properly
like you see like drug addicts and [__]
how they reuse the same needles and all
that crap and you look at them on like
like homeless people on the street and
you're like God damn we're talking about
person's neck it's like that's what's
wrong with it they're using dirty ass
needles so there's a whole process
behind all this [__] that's that's why
like when we were like I just want to
get off their eyes it's not like that it
isn't like that at all you don't just
get on them if you want to take like pop
anavar like that [__] fighter did
sure whatever you can pop some handlebar
but getting on steroids is not just
getting on steroids there are costs you
have to take into consideration that
you're not taking consideration as far
as health goes as far as like hospital
bills how much do you have to pay
monthly for steroids that really just
depends like they're honestly what's the
range they're cheaper than supplements
really oh damn damn more than
ashwagandha is pretty expensive that
stuff is expensive how long have you
been on steroids uh this will be three
three years four years let's ask the
serious questions what did it do to your
penis
dick nothing balls like I said earlier
it's like a Brazilian butt lift for your
testicles which is good for a
middle-aged white men why are you sack
oh you guys sag that's your style yeah
that's your style and my [__] really
shag so when I got that tuck the the nut
tuck it was great what about your thing
does it make your dick bigger uh it
actually can increase blood flow to
every area wow there's hope so I went
from like a solid two and a half to like
2.75 wow
take steroids their clits get all huge
that's a viralization effect it's the
masculine features that occur so is it
turning into a penis no it's not turning
to a penis oh
sexual organs just get more blood flow
to them and it can it can grow the
clitoris I Wonder If They Come Harder
oh they do oh
wait so let me think about it if your
dick was like extra stimulated come on
when you say your ball sacks disappear
does that mean the skin gets tighter or
your balls actually get smaller is
smaller and they tuck up and that pulls
the skin up and whenever skin is not
like elastic for a long time then that
also kind of shrinks the skin around so
it's like a neutered dog I mean I
wouldn't say exactly like that but it's
close they're just gone yeah they're
surgically cut off it's like they got a
raisin on their right there what's the
worst side effect you've ever had
associated with steroids
um last year I got an abscess and I had
to pull out of my show I got an abscess
during Peak Week what's abscess uh you
can get them just from like ingrown
hairs and [__] like a body pimple
basically yeah
they go you can't be going on the show
with that thing well not only that but
it causes like a systemic response where
you're just like a watery [__] mess
and you're trying to go on stage looking
shredded and looking all big and lean
and all that but uh yeah you I would not
have gotten on stage with that like
people that get on stage with lumps are
idiots I don't know why you would do
that I've seen it so many times you get
more you get points marked off oh [__]
yeah somebody lost the Olympia because
of that one time what about people that
like uh I don't know which story they're
taking but they get like
either crazy night sweats uh nightmares
maybe even the most insane panic attacks
have you ever experienced any of that
stuff night sweats sometimes uh that
usually that's something like a 19 or
like a trend that I was talking about
um mental aspect of pharmacology I can
feel it the best way I can describe when
you're on a bunch of anabolics is
there's like a a burden like you're
constantly a little more anxious than
you normally would be
um but you're still like I said if
you're
level-headed and you've introspected
enough and you like have done any form
of meditation or you understand the way
the world [__] works you're not going
to turn to this crazy [__] monster
that's like out to get everybody and
have panic attacks and [__] like that uh
so I've I've hardly experienced that I
don't have like high anxiety I don't
have depression or anything like that
but if you do things like 19 doors
especially or something you might want
to stay clear of
um I I know people who have had really
severe uh kind of like mood swings
because of this stuff do more guys sit
on you or girls that was my next
question I'm gonna say this straight up
the [__] old adage and joke about not
getting [__] because your jacked is the
stupidest [__] ever I've only gotten
[__] because I'm Jack this is nothing
yeah legit people would just slide into
the DMS or something or like or in real
life or how does it look yeah if you
could like generalize the type of woman
who hits on a bodybuilder
is it other bodybuilder women in that
happens a lot yeah I don't know I think
if you just like aren't an idiot know
how to talk to people it's not that hard
to the same women that would hit on
anybody but any woman that says they
don't like muscles is full of [__] and
they all do I've had I've specifically
tried to like pick up chicks who are
like that's gross yeah it always works
it's just like it's because they like
the heart and you got a big one because
of steroids 2.75
what's the worst side effect you've
experienced with steroids then uh just
the options is the abscess I think and
smooth balls getting that cut out sucked
oh was it massive it was huge her
pictures cut out yeah or was it axis bad
enough to where like they had to go in
and like remove oil like that it was
like draining yeah yeah they had to
squeeze it out I've had a job yeah you
can get it from just like [__]
ingrown hairs do they have to stick in
the [__] little rubber drain thing
too and then pull it out a week later
how big was it terrible uh my entire
right ass cheek was like two times the
size of normal and my ass is already
huge so that's oh my God it was crazy I
can show you pictures okay if you had a
kid and they wanted to jump on steroids
later on would you
uh recommend against it or would you
support it man these are hard questions
for me to answer because I'm a [__]
nerd yeah I'm like really big into this
technological singularity what the hell
does that mean exactly like the moment
of Singularity just like the eyes
you're a part of the cyborg crew like
you believe in like
enhancing as hard as you can yeah dude
yeah but uh no I think Western medicine
is going to take care of a lot of these
problems there's already drugs in um
drugs and clinical trials that are like
shown to increase muscle mass decreased
fat mass that aren't anabolic steroids
that are like coming right now like
ozympic is a fat loss agent can I buy
these things yeah yes yeah how about
Hydroxycut remember that
absolutely
that works yeah that was the first such
[__] caffeine I would clearly tell
them no because I know there's better
[__] coming that won't affect your
health so much oh wow yeah we might have
like a super organ in the future that
just talks to all your other organs it's
like hey you're sick here even if you
don't know you know like we'll just grow
a new organ yeah there's all kinds of
crazy [__] that's coming man like
nanotech but yeah those types of
questions are hard for me to answer and
so I'm just a [__] nerd earlier you
mentioned uh the you don't want kids or
yeah so like uh my entire family is like
white trash genetics like I have 15
siblings oh it's a genetic thing 15
siblings yeah and actually I have morphs
when I count like adopted and stuff but
um
they want to adopt as well my mom
currently does damn she's a kid collect
adoption like this like my sister's on
meth my she has six kids let's say and
then she goes to prison right and then
now my mom is like well I don't want to
go to this okay that's the best thing
for them like don't make me know what to
say my cousin had like uh her dad on a
meth lab she was on meth and then she
went to prison
she adopted her two kids one of them's
autistic because she did drugs while she
was pregnant with him like a [__]
idiot that's my family heritage so I'm
just like
being that I'm So Into biology and stuff
like that I know these things so I'll
give it 10 more years and I'll just have
a [__] petri dish kit if I want to
have a kid you know like make that thing
in the [__] lab and let's cut out the
bad stuff so you're like predisposed to
addiction and math let's cut that out
yeah like I'm not trying to put that
burden on like whoever I decide to share
my life with but you don't think so
because you're so smart that you're
you're the one breaking the cycle
genetically it wouldn't matter like
they're they're still predisposed to
addiction yeah they're so predisposed to
White Trash meth bingo
is it
I'm loving Walmart and smoking so much
[__] like alcoholics and yeah poor
decision making and low like just all
kinds of stuff in my family that I'm
just like let's just not put that on
anybody else being being such a science
dude um what do you think about
epigenetics pretty [__] dope okay
because then going back to if everything
is predisposed but if epigenetics can
you can change it by environmental and
behavioral things is that
even possible it's like 80 20. okay yeah
which is very well studied it's like
most of the so that's why twin studies
are [__] sweet I don't know if this
is true but I did hear that Bruce Buffer
and then uh Michael Buffer Michael
Buffer the brothers right and they
didn't know they didn't know and they
got into announcing they were hard
workers oh they didn't know each other
no they were broken they both does the
yeah
right that's like those these things are
so crazy it was it's been in their
system wow
they both were like ladies and gentlemen
it's not crazy this is crazy let's get
ready to rumble like was that them both
do you think they did it independently
independently let's get ready to rumble
they have different catchphrases but
their occupations
one says Let's Get Right Rumble one says
um what's the other one say it's time
it's time yeah they say different things
but they it's so this is how strong
genetics are they didn't know their
brothers and they independently arrived
pretty much at the same place wow
17 minute uh seven second portion of the
video when we start to turn up the heat
and stuff what is your real thing yeah
absolutely what is your porn preference
porn preference
um legitimately I am only into Latinas
and Asians wow yeah I do not tell you
why it was a mariachi Samurai
Mike tells Jerry's
Jerry's what's a Jerry
wait wait just say you only dated black
girls in high school in high school but
I was from a white trash town we didn't
have [__] Latinas lived my first
Latino was in college and I was like
what the [__] is that
how do I talk to that because uh so and
then she was my girlfriend so Mike and
him they work in the same company and
then I was shooting a video with Mike
silent Mike no Mike is myself oh he's
our head Sports scientist at RP yeah he
does what I do except better and he was
his former student in college so he has
a PHD uh we're shooting a video at
barbell and uh Mike was like oh man
there's just so many Jerry's in here and
I was like
Jerry is that a derogatory term he goes
no he's like it's Southeast Asians and
Jared would love them
[__] okay
that should be more specific they got to
be around like when I go to places and
like Asians are trying to like wipe
their skin and stuff I'm like where are
your field workers
[Laughter]
Jerry's
[Music]
why is the term Jerry uh because they
call me Jerry instead of Jared because
because if you're a Latina and you say
Jared it's Kitty Oh Daddy
[Laughter]
yeah because they kept saying Jerry's
the whole time I was like what is this
Jerry thing I can introduce you to a lot
of Jerry's yo [__] tell him I said
what's up tell myself I know the
demographic of these that's why this
wasn't for you this was for me dog hey
Jerry we do have a lot of Latinas and
Asian girls watch I know
oh man what's the uh percentage of the
people that DM you the Jerry's that DM
you for us and then you're like I'm
gonna respond the follow through yeah it
all it all goes that way right
but it's not part of the market so you
got a 100 chance to me this man dude is
that crutches bro you kidding me if you
got a fantasy of being with somebody
that's got muscles bigger than Bart
he'll fly you out dude he'll fly you out
to me it's like
oh here's my technique and my squat like
what can I do better I'm like she's
trying to hit it clearly because then
she sends you a video of her squatting
and it's nothing but ass
clearly said Jared your Technique videos
that's interesting I didn't know that
that was like a way in that's cool it's
a way in wow can you give me some hell
there's an algorithmic method to all
this too like if I'm at the gym and I
see like a chick who's checking me out I
will tag myself in the gym
I'll tag myself so then she could hit
you up later it happens all the time
yeah because you know she's searching
new age dating I don't know these
techniques tag yourself in the gym
that's crazy wow that's a cool thing
makes a lot of sense He makes himself
available you gotta start working out
more you guys
we gotta hop on this art wheel
on the RP program I'm gonna tag myself
in every Planet Fitness today
you're just gonna get nothing but truck
drivers in your DM
foreign